fans are of course rabid they know their
Star Wars mythology very well we have a
fan on the show our associate producer
Jordan slansky he has a gripe with the
original trilogy and he's asked if it's
okay if he addresses this right now
it's is that okay is you guys fair
totally up to Harrison okay you're okay
with us here when you say Jordan would
you step in here please
[Music]
Luke Skywalker lightsaber from the
original 1977 film is made from a
vintage Graflex camera flash it had
seven plastic grips attached to the
handle and a Texas Instruments exact her
calculator LED bubble strip when the
lightsaber returns in the Empire Strikes
Back we only have six rips on the handle
and each grip had a notch cut out to
accommodate a visible fastener
additionally the bubble strip had been
replaced by a vintage computer connector
board the force awakens trailer once
again features the same lightsaber still
with the correct vintage computer board
and still with the notches cut out of
the handle grips as we last saw them
however it's unclear whether there are
six or seven grips on the handle can you
please confirm whether the force awakens
Luke Skywalker lightsaber has six or
seven grips well it's a great question
and definitely something for hair
enhancer maybe
Thank You Jordan had one other favor
Jordan you brought something it's
important to you yeah one of the pieces
of memorabilia in my collection in fact
the flagship piece is a Lego Millennium
Falcon that I put together in 2010
they're selling for about five thousand
dollars now and it took about 60
man-hours to create and I display with
pride but it would really mean the world
to me if Harrison could sign it Wow sure
thank you guys so much Wow now it's a
very delicate long time yeah
[Applause]
that's bad don't worry about it what you
still you have the pen okay here okay
make it much more valuable now is when
we hear a muffled shot in a bike
[Applause]